excellente nouvelle dans le monde vers
avec l'arrivée d'oculus quest oculus
ques c'est quoi c'est un casque de
réalité virtuelle une solution en tout
cas de réalité virtuelle qui va vous
permettre de faire des choses que vous
ne pouviez pas faire avant au niveau la
veille
[Musique]
c'était une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec boulanger boulanger m'a
proposé de tester le casque de réalité
virtuelle d'oculus oculus quest merci je
serai très sympa ça permet justement aux
rites voir vous en parler l'averse à
tout que j'aime bien
j'ai eu ce truc là là vous mettiez au
c'est votre smartphone laquelle comme ce
soir notre trop voilà ça faisait de la
dr c'était bien ce que je trouvais
vraiment génial avec ça c'est que vous
aviez de la réalité virtuelle mais sans
absolument aucun câble ça c'est très
bien mais la qualité était pas terrible
vous faisiez pas grand chose voilà c'est
un petit peu what the fuck à côté de ça
il ya d'autres solutions qui existent
mais ça et ça c'est pas possible ça
c'est trop compliqué alors c'est bien
nous faisait des trucs pas mal c'est pas
inintéressant mais ça pour moi non noël
ça marche pas pour moi ce qui est
vraiment cool c'est ça c'est plus quest
ça résout beaucoup de problèmes
savez-vous vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes
on va vulgariser le truc vous avez un
petit ordinateur à l'intérieur vous avez
tous qui est là tout est là dedans vous
n'avez absolument aucun câble ce qui
fait que vous avez absolument une
liberté de mouvement qui est juste
dingue
vous le mettez dans votre tête vous
allez où vous voulez vous bouger comme
vous voulez vous faites ce que vous
voulez c'est vraiment bien et la voyez
ce qui est génial c'est que dans le
studio je n'ai pas paramétré mais je
vous vois quand même je sais exactement
vous n'êtes pas ce que je peux dire
paramétrer ma pièce danger l'espèce de
vue de vision où je vois mes marques et
je me vois en noir et blanc
c'est un peu particulier mais par contre
c'est vraiment cool parce que je peux
venir paramétrer mon espace pour venir
jouer très très facilement et ça c'est
vraiment pratique donc c'est un solution
je dirais tout en vous avez votre verre
qui est là mais ça serait rien sans des
contrôleurs vous êtes bien évidemment
tout petit contrôleur qui sont juste là
qui se traîne très facilement en main
très intuitive c'est vraiment un truc
est vraiment bien et je trouve que là
dessus au cul juste avec son os que
juste quest est en train de changer la
donne au niveau de la réalité virtuelle
la boîte ressemble à ça okumus quest bon
assez simple à ces pratiques donc on a
la boîte on a ici le casque alors
qu'est-ce qui est vachement bien avec ce
casque déjà qu'on de mettre sur votre
tête
hyper facile vous tirez il vient et se
positionne des petits scratch pour
dérégler à votre tête c'est vraiment
très très très très facile vous levez
vous mettez vous tirez tac vous poser
cette terre me
et sarko n'est directement quand le
casque est intéressant voter donc ça va
venir à lui mais quand vous l'enlevez ça
s'éteint donc a pas de besoin il n'y a
pas de bouton pour l'allumer pour
éteindre besoin d'un petit capteur qui
est juste là c'est très confort très
sympa ça c'est vraiment un boulot qui
est vraiment très très bien fait autre
point qui est cool si vous avez des
petits haut parleurs qui sont situées de
chaque côté donc lorsque vous avez votre
casque sur la tête et bien vous écouter
la musique le son qui viennent là vous
avez un bouton de volume vous pouvez
venir régler ici mais vous n'êtes pas
coupé de votre environnement si par
contre voulait profiter de l'expérience
un peu plus immersive avec des écouteurs
et bien vous avez une prise jack l'âme
et une prise jack de l'autre côté vous
pouvez acheter des petits écouteurs
oculus uniquement des écouteurs oculus
vous les prenez vous avez un trou pour
chaque oreille
ces pratiques à l'avant le truc qui est
vraiment très intéressant c'est que ce
cas cela vous permet d'avoir six degrés
de liberté c'est à dire que à la
différence d'un casque vert lorsque vous
allez avant ses accus et bien votre
environnement ne va pas bouger là avec
votre casque au plus juste votre
environnement va bouger c'est ça qui est
vraiment intéressant parce que la voyez
vous avez des capteurs tout autour qui
vont reconnaître votre environnement et
qui vont permettre effectivement bien
lorsque vous allez bouger de bouger dans
votre environnement et vous mouvoir donc
ça c'est bien et en plus si vous permet
de reconnaître vos contrôleurs dont vous
savoir où sont positionnés vos
contrôleurs dans l'espace ce qui fait
que vous avez des jeux pouvez venir vous
blesser et bien vous allez réellement
vous blesser dans le jeu vous lever vous
montez avancer reculer vous déplacez
vous le faites en réalité avec ce casque
est là et c'est vraiment ça qui est bien
avec ses soutiens tout en un c'est que
ça vous évite d'installer des capteurs
aux quatre coins de votre pièce
tout est là dedans les capteurs sont là
il permet de vous reconnaitre voir la
position de repérer vos contrôleurs et
ça c'est vraiment génial
on a donc une solution tout en un pour
la réalité virtuelle domestique qui vous
permet avec très peu de choses
un casque et deux contrôleurs de vous
installer où vous voulez comme vous
voulez très simplement pour jouer au jeu
vous voulez dans votre catalogue sans
avoir besoin de vous embêter vous partez
en vacances vous l'emmener avec vous
vous avez juste à configurer votre zone
et vous êtes repartis donc ça s'est
vraiment bien et c'est pour ça que ce
casque oculus quest pas ce cast et ses
contrôleurs cette solution tout cas faut
vraiment venir renversé révolutionner
est chamboulé la réalité virtuelle parce
qu'aujourd'hui le monde de la réalité
virtuelle et bien il faut un pc il vous
avez besoin de câble de trucs comme ça
et ça c'est juste pas de bien avec ça
plus besoin de cabourg
pousser les limites et à mon avis cette
solution là elle est géniale pour deux
raisons la première je vous dis sega
vous passez d'un ordinateur donc pas
utiliser vous voulez vous partez une
soirée des amis vous pouvez le mettre
vous pouvez jouer avec des amis à plat
tout cas la réalité virtuelle sera
enfermé davantage mais vous pouvez vous
challenge et politique un petit point
d'eau donc ça s'est vraiment bien et
puis surtout le fait d'avoir ces degrés
de liberté ces mouvements voyez vous
vous déplacez comme ça et bien lui
valent savoir que c'est en train de
devenir des places est de vous mouvoir
donc trouve que c'est vraiment vraiment
bien et se casse que là il inaugure en
tout cas d'une nouvelle ère d'une ère
grand public au niveau de la réalité
virtuelle pour moi la réalité virtuelle
salle a complètement révolutionné le jeu
vidéo bien évidemment ça enferme
davantage les lorsque vous jouez avec
des amis au réseau bien vous je me tous
ensemble avec chacun avec son petit
casque oculus prévoux challenge qu'on
soit vraiment vraiment cool
l'installation base est vraiment hyper
simple vous prenez votre casque jusque
là tout va bien
vous mettez des piles jusque là tout va
bien vous rechargez votre casque en usb
tissés avec le cap qui fournit qui est
quand même relativement ça c'est aussi
bien une fois que tout est chargé
installez vous le mettez sur votre tête
vous venez régler si avec un petit
bouton l'espacement vous calibré tout
pour que vous soyez complètement à
l'aise et c'est parti bien évidemment
vous créez un compte
hocus vous téléchargez l'application
oculus dans votre smartphone vous
installez l'application vous activez
votre casque vous aurez un petit code
bluetooth qui apparaîtra à l'intérieur
et vous êtes parti l'expérience peut
enfin commencer
vous avez un didacticiel qui est très
simple vous montrer comment utiliser les
contrôleurs comment vous déplacer
comment calibré votre zone enfin vous
êtes vraiment pris en main du début
jusqu'à la fin du moment vous ouvrez la
boîte puisque l'on annonce de pouvoir
commencer à jouer c'est vraiment très
facile et voyez ce qui est souhaité par
occultant et c'est très clair c'est très
transparent s'est faite démocratiser
toujours plus la réalité virtuelle que
tout un chacun puisse jouer très
facilement à la réalité virtuelle vous
prenez votre caf vous le positionner et
ça y est vous pouvez commencer à jouer
un autre monde s'ouvre à vous et ça
c'est vraiment génial moi je trouve ça
vraiment passionnant j'adore la vert
mais voyez c'est toujours embêté j'ai un
autre casque d'une marque concurrente
mais si tu es en train de dire bon alors
faut que je le prenne fond je le branche
faut que je sorte de sa boîte vous
installe mon kit c'est juste pénible
ce qui fait qu'au final on n'y joue pas
à la vierge il joue très peur je fais
vraiment génial et alors là vert avec un
casque comme ça le bien vers samsung
avec son casque oculus
c'est bien c'était bien pour commence à
découvrir mais on est passé à autre
chose et ce qui est vraiment génial
c'est qu'avec ça on est enfin passer à
autre chose
l'averse ouvre de nouveaux horizons je
trouve ça j passionnant vous avez deux
petites lentilles pour me regarder vous
allez deux écrans oled en fait à
l'intérieur de 1440 par 1600 pixels à 72
images par seconde c'est fluide sauf que
le résultat est vraiment fluide
moi je sais que la verge suis assez
sensible encore il ya des jeux de suite
boury n'a plus trop au bout d'un moment
j'ai rapidement la nausée pour l'instant
tous les jeux auxquels j'ai joué là
dedans je me sens bien hyper confort
vraiment c'est hyper agréable et je dois
reconnaître que l'expérience est
vraiment bien alors pareil au niveau des
contrôleurs contrôleurs du ciel comme ça
voyez ses marques et wright
vous pouvez bien enlevé le petit scotch
si vous voulez moi j'ai gardé jamais sa
part toujours comme ça right left vous
avez deux boutons boutons rabou tomber
le petit contrôleur qui fait aussi
office de bouton vous pouvez venir
appuyer dessus vous avez cette petite
zone là pour jouer là pour attraper hop
là je viens j'attrape ou j'appuie avec
mon doigt lorsque je joue à des jeux
c'est très facile c'est vraiment hyper
intuitive bien sûr les petits dragons
pour venir vous protéger seul truc que
je pourrais regretter avec ses deux
petits contrôleur c'est que lorsqu'on
veut faire des actions dans les jeux et
bien avec les grand art ceux-là vont
venir se cogner donc ça des fois c'est
vrai que c'est le truc qui est un peu
grand qui pourrait être être un peu
revue donc ça se cogne ça ces points un
peu négatif et à côté de ça et tourner
sur un processeur de 'smartphones' un
snapdragon 835 ce même pas leurs
arrières génération 845 pour carrément
855 est sorti l'année dernière sans 835
mais qui va parfaitement bien
l'expérience de verre est vraiment très
agréable c'est fluide c'est sympa c'est
smooth c'est vraiment pratique
alors bien évidemment vous avez accès à
tout un catalogue avec des jeux des jeux
qui va falloir venir acheter
bill saveurs qui est un jeu qui est très
connu qui coûte un peu moins de 30 euros
vous avez valeur il mord pas la 999 qui
te suis beaucoup plus accessible vous
avez pas mal de jeu on se retrouve
beaucoup autour des 25 30 euros
vous avez aussi des petits jeux gratuits
en fin et tout cas c'est sympa à
découvrir
il y en a un peu pour tout le monde
c'est vrai que ça c'est sa part au gala
du karting
on va pouvoir s'envoyer en l'air et fut
en plus ce qui est assez marrant c'est
que vous avez l'application netflix nous
avons créé une espèce de
deux salons virtuels vous allez pouvoir
regarder neflix pas envers vous n'êtes
pas du tout en immersion mais sur un
écran face de vous alors j'ai regardé au
début vite fait foncer un peu marrant je
suis pas sûr que ce soit tout le plus
dingue pour regarder d'être flix mais
bon dans l'absolu pour paris vous avez
pas mal de petites choses assez rigolote
d'applications réveiller votre cerveau
ça sans ajouter très connu aussi sa
superbe robe vert qui offre une super
expérience
il ya pas mal de choses moi ce que je
constate c'est de devenir voire
d'essayer voyez vous avez youtube br il
faut savoir que les jeux vous avez
oculiste quest sont pas forcément
compatibles avec rift égaux vous avez un
catalogue à part vous n'allez pas et
donc à voir l'intégralité du catalogue
sur votre auguste quest mais avec tout
ce qui a déjà c'est pas mal et puis ça
va continuer à évoluer dans les temps à
venir
côté expérience ne sera vraiment très
pratique en plus ce qui est sympa avec
les manettes c'est que vous avez un
effet au tour apt x et du retour
vibrations donc lorsque vous avez une
action où vous prenez des coups sa vie
c'est marrant avec le curiste quest vous
avez 2 à 3 heures d'autonomie ça va
dépendre si vous jouez à des jeux aussi
vous gagnez tout simplement des vidéos
au travers de votre casque il vous le
recharger très rapidement en usb type c
en deux heures alors très rapidement
vous me direz deux ans n'était pas hyper
rapide mais vous n'allez pas jouer
pendant des heures avec vous n'avez pas
des besoins de fou donc lorsque vous
avez déjà fait une session de deux
heures et croyez moi c'est déjà énorme
vous le posez vous le branchez vous
revenez quelques heures après c'est
tranquille le cerveau un peu reposé vous
pouvez repartir ça c'est assez cool 5 à
ce qui vient évidemment tout de suite
déjà disponibles sorti il ya quelques
jours vous trouvez en deux
configurations 64 go de stockage à 449
euros ou alors 128 gb de stockage à 549
euros
bien évidemment le casque la complète
les contrôleurs la boîte le chargeur
toussa toussa attention si vous voulez
acheter
les écouteurs jack ça va être en plus
sur le site d'oculus ou chez tous les
bons revendeurs comme boulanger entre
autres vous allez pouvoir retrouver
aussi un étui vous allez pouvoir acheter
en plus pour venir le promener et
l'emmener avec vous parce que c'est un
casque portatif la réalité virtuelle
c'est toujours compliqué de pouvoir vous
la montrer de vous la montre en images
effectivement on peut toujours dire
allez on insère des screenshots me vois
en train de vous c'est marrant mais en
fait c'est un truc qui s'expérimente
pour moi la meilleure façon d'en parler
la meilleure façon de vous communiquer
ça c'est de le faire en vous parlant
mettant des mots dessus
pour moi c'est très clairement un grand
pas qu'ils aient fait un grand pas en
avant sur la réalité virtuelle
quand j'étais gamin je rêvais de pouvoir
effectivement jouer à des jeux vidéos
avec un casque
j'ai pas des choses comme ça je m'agite
espèce de gros casque sur la tête qui
vous emmener dans un espèce de monde
virtuel comme dans des films comme total
recall et compagnie enfin encore autre
chose mais c'est vraiment ça que
j'imaginais alors laclavère on n'est pas
complètement mais on avance on avance
pas par pas et on va qu'on progresse
le fait d'avoir un truc qui est autonome
avec ses degrés de liberté c'est
vraiment top c'est une belle avancée au
niveau de la réalité virtuelle grand
public je trouve ça vraiment
encourageant je sais pas vous ce que
vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous trouvé
ça intéressant oui non pas comment
est-ce que vous jouez ce que vous
utilisez la vère est-ce que vous pensez
que des cases comme oculus quest c'est
dur à dire inventant parle vite oculus
quest permettre de s'affranchir
effectivement des pc pouvoir jouer
partout est ce que vous pourriez
l'emmener avec vous est ce que vous
pourriez succombé je vous dis point que
je pourrais regretter un peu négatif
c'est les contrôleurs qui vont
s'entrechoquer
bon c'est vraiment anecdotique ça dépend
vraiment des je pense à bien configurer
votre pièce je les configurer un petit
peu serré lorsque j'ai joué j'ai mis un
coup dans un mur ça fait mal ça n'a pas
cassé sa solide mais ça peut
relativement faire mal
il ya aussi encore un tout petit peu cet
effet de gris qui se fait ressentir
on voit un petit peu les grilles mais
c'est vraiment pas grand chose il ya
quand même une une belle avancée on le
voit beaucoup moins que ce qu'il y avait
dans des solutions précédentes ya quand
même eu un beau travail fait de la part
de oculus et là dessus sur ce cas ce que
là c'est pas encore une solution qui
complètement aboutie où on est vraiment
transporter ailleurs mais je trouve que
papa repas en avance et qu'en tout cas
cette solution elle est vraiment hyper
intéressante si vous voulez vous initier
la vère si vous voulez jouer avec de la
vère si vous voulez pas besoin détails
qu'un ordi pas vous embêter avec des
câbles si vous voulez pouvoir emmener
votre verre partout avec vous oculus
quest c'est ce qu'il vous faut
à demain ciao